[Musique]
bonjour à tous soyez les bienvenus pour
dimanche en politique votre émission de
débat en franche comté au menu ce matin
le projet de réforme des retraites que
le premier ministre edouard philippe est
venu présenter à lons le saunier jeudi
soir alors quelle retraite pour demain
on va en parler on va en débattre avec
nos invités eric alauzet le député la
république en marche du doubs et sur ce
plateau
face à lui jean marie sermier député les
républicains du jura vous avez croisé le
premier ministre à lons le saunier il y
a quelques jours et bastien photo élues
municipales et départementales de
belfort animateur national de la gauche
républicaine et socialistes bonjour à
tous les trois merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation comme chaque semaine
vous pouvez commenter sur les réseaux
sociaux se débat avec le mot ds qui
s'affiche dit mme paul fc comme dimanche
en politique franche comté alors
messieurs edouard philippe était donc à
lons le saunier dans le jura jeudi soir
est juste avant de rencontrer une
centaine de parents d'élèves dans le
cadre de la consultation sur la réforme
des retraites il nous a accordé à france
3 franche comté un entretien exclusif
on regarde un court extrait en régie
juste après il ya beaucoup de
possibilités pour passer des systèmes
actuels au système futur on peut faire
tous brutalement une certaine année on
peut faire des phases de transitions
plus ou moins longue
on peut imaginer plusieurs façons de
rentrer dans la fin et il ne s'agit ni
de reculer ni d'avancé ni de bousculer
il s'agit de discuter et de prendre une
décision éclairée négociée et concertée
ça se fait dans le calme ça c'était dans
la discussion
[Musique]
ni reculer ni avancer ni bousculés mais
discuter surtout pour rassurer on
al'impression eric alauzet les grands
principes
la situation aujourd'hui est pas la
meilleure qu'il soit on a des retraités
pauvres en un système injuste 42 régime
instable on sait pas pour nos enfants
quel sera le niveau d de retraite en
tout cas aussi qu'il sera moins
important en proportion de ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui à cotisation égale et il
n'est pas lisible parce que la moyenne
des régimes de retraite pour une
personne ces trois régimes donc ça va
pas il faut changer le système mais le
gouvernement lance un grand débat elle
c'est à dire que tout est sur la table
qu'on peut tout discuter il ya des
grands principes sur l'équité sur le
maintien des retraites pour nos enfants
sur le seul régime sur la notion de
retraite emploi ce qui n'est pas la
retraite par points on restera le régime
de répartition nous sont les générations
actuelles qui finance la retraite pour
les anciens et non pas un régime on
cotiseraient pour sa propre retraite
donc tout ça est très claire en revanche
il faut prendre le temps on sait très
bien où vous souvenez la famille fameuse
formule de michel rocard il a de quoi
avec la rentrée de faire sauter hui 3 au
dimanche 5 ou 6 gouvernement donc il
faut y aller paisiblement avec un
objectif de protéger les plus faibles
ça c'est moi mon viatique jean marie
sermier qu'est ce que vous attendez de
ce débat et plus généralement de la
réforme annoncée par le gouvernement
vous savez dans notre société les
retraites c'est un acquis essentiel et
c'est un stabilisateur de la société
parce que c'est tout à fait normal que
quand nos concitoyens ont travaillé
toute une carrière il puisse connaître
d'abord le niveau de leur retraite
et puis être certain que les retraites
seront servis or on est obligé de
constater aujourd'hui que quand on
s'adresse aux jeunes générations
quand on s'adresse aux jeunes qui ont
moins de 30 ans eh bien ils ne sont pas
sur eux de pouvoir un jour bénéficier de
la retraite donc ils sont réformés
réformer et c'est très fort mais elle
est attendue mais il ya longtemps qu'il
ya déjà eu un certain nombre de réformes
si aujourd'hui nous sommes en système
équilibré à peu près équilibré c'est
tout simplement parce que par exemple en
2003 avec la réforme fillon
il ya eu des avancées qui ont permis
aujourd'hui
de pouvoir équilibrer le système mais si
on ne le fait pas aujourd'hui
eh bien demain les jeunes seront en
difficulté simplement il faut décider à
moment donné et ça fait deux ans et demi
qu'on concertent bastien photo elle est
souhaitable cette réforme des retraites
tout ça est toujours très général alors
quand vous entendez les principes
énoncés par le premier ministre ces
rutilants comme une nouvelle voiture
principe d'universalité il faut que le
régime soit universel solide et juste at
il dit hier soir à la télévision qui
peut objectivement s'opposer à ce type
de formules personnes ou des gens
particulièrement pervers bon alors comme
nous ne sommes pas des gens pervers on
s'y oppose pas sauf qu'il faut ensuite
entrer dans le détail et dans le détail
c'est là que pour l'instant on est juste
dans l'ouverture d'esprit la négociation
va discuter tout mais il faut savoir de
quoi nous allons débattre de quoi nous
allons parler alors la seule chose que
nous ayons aujourd'hui sur la table
qu'ils soient tangibles
c'est le rapport de le voir sur lequel
il ya un certain nombre d'orientations
qui ont été fixés j'en parle saluera
dont il faut parler a été chargé d'un
rapport au ministre qui pour l'heure ne
dit pas grand chose oui mais est-ce
qu'il faut réformer le système des
retraites mais réservé le système des
retraites je vais vous donner un exemple
très concret pour qu'on se comprenne en
les études qui sont formulées estime
qu'il y aura un trou de 10 milliards
d'euros dans le régime des retraites
savez vous que si ce qu'on dénonce
depuis des années
l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes étaient effectives dans le
pays
on aurait déjà réduit les deux tiers du
problème qui se présente à nous en 2025
donc ça c'est une piste est un sujet
sérieux parce que voyez-vous les
libéraux depuis on en train de vivre la
sixième saison d'un mauvais épisode il
ya eu 93 balladur 95 ça a mal fini pour
juppé 2003 2007 2010 et voici donc
maintenant l'épisode 2019 2020
en réalité à travers tout cela arrive à
tout révéler mon sens il a quand même
mené sa patte à travers à travers moi
surtout de cette période évidemment mais
à travers tout ça des grillades large
tout le monde autour de cette table a
fini par soutenir un jour quelques fois
oui mais vous ne me ferez pas dire ce
que je ne veux pas dire dans cette
affaire les libéraux fidèles à leur
réputation ne comprennent l'économie
qu'avec une seule chose leur petit
carnet leur petit crayon et il ne
quoique les dépenses jean marie sermier
a raison jean marie sermier à raison
bastien faudot vous avez appartenu aux
mrc qui à un moment a soutenu des
gouvernements mais qui ont réformé les
retraites également que j'ai soutenu
françois hollande en 2012 et que comme
la plupart des français j'ai été
extrêmement déçu de ce qu'il a fait
évidemment et je le dis bien volontiers
ici à l'antenne
eric alauzet sur les motivations de la
réforme le rapport donne voix dans son
tout premier paragraphe dit que le
système de retraite actuel est à l'
équilibre ou proches de l'équilibré
financier pourquoi réformer alors il l'a
été en 2019
c'était malheureusement la seule année
et on repart dès 2020 sur un déficit de
3,4 milliards et ça va augmenter dans
les années à venir parce qu'on est venu
à la fin de l'effet des réformes
antérieures celles que jean marie
sermier a cité qui était notamment
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
c'en est un des éléments on a poussé
aussi les l'augmentation des cotisations
savais qu'à un jeune aujourd'hui qui
travaillèrent jeunes moins jeunes
d'ailleurs ceux qui travaillent
consacrent 28 % de leurs revenus au
financement des retraites il y à 40 ans
leak les retraités d'aujourd'hui
consacrer 20%
on a augmenté de 8 points la part des du
salaire et ça ne suffit pas ça ne suffit
pas le recul de l'âge de la retraite ne
suffit pas il a permis d'aller aux
données d'âge de la retraite mais
malloire l'énergie solaire après tu es
ma nana qu'on ya quinze jours à rodez
devant d'ailleurs un panel de français
comme edouard philippe
à lons le saunier jeudi soir emmanuel
macron à dire on ne touchera pas aux 62
ans l'âge légal
en revanche il faudra cotiser plus
longtemps pour avoir une retraite pleine
on est un peu dans l'hypocrisie l'a
complètement complètement parce que ce
qui est important aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir comment on va pouvoir financer
les retraites parce qu'il faut que les
retraités futur et la certitude d'avoir
des pensions de bon niveau
autrement c'est facile d'évoquer la
nécessité de maintenir des retraites
c'est facile d'évoquer la nécessité de
garder l'âge de la retraite à 62 ans si
c'est pour avoir des retraites de misère
derrière je pense qu'aujourd'hui
par exemple la catégorie des
agriculteurs vous le savez bien on des
retraites quasiment indécente
donc il faut trouver des solutions mais
l'ouvrier qui a été au smic toute sa vie
il a aussi une retraite extrêmement
petit et ils n'arrivent pas à vivre
donc l'objectif il est pas
de travailler moi il est de permettre
aux retraités de pouvoir avoir une
retraite décente et de pouvoir vivre
décemment
alors en 1945 vous aviez si cotisant
pour un retraité
on va bientôt d'avoir moins de 2
cotisant pour un retraité
c'est un fait aujourd'hui cette énième
réforme des retraites jean marie sermier
elle suscite beaucoup d'inquiétude vous
avez raison je vous propose d'écouter
trois jurassiens ils ont assisté à la
réunion publique menée par edouard
philippe
jeudi soir à lons lucie tirer leur a
demandé à l'issue de cette réunion
s'il était convaincu c'est un échange
mais aucune réponse sur le fond
c'est-à-dire quand maintiennent
leurs systèmes vivants leur système par
points
ça va pas de cpc c'est un système qui
fonctionne pas du tout il était honnête
dans ce qu'il a dit enfin je pense
il a développé il a développé de façon
assez longue d'une question qui lui
avait été posée maintenant le gros
problème ça va être mise en application
il a répondu en
en expliquant que les pénibilités à
certains niveaux seraient reconnus
notamment le travail de nuit
après je pense qu'il ya encore un
travail à faire voilà sur les modalités
de cette reconnaissance
vous êtes satisfaite de sa réponse je
suis satisfait tout et on l'a bien
compris sur le sujet des retraites c'est
extrêmement compliqué bastien faudot n'y
at il pas un courage politique à
s'attaquer à ces quarante deux régimes
de retraite et à vouloir simplifier
offrir plus de lisibilité aux français
non mais d'abord les carottes de régimes
de retraite correspondent à des
situations spécifiques qu'il faut avoir
le courage surtout de reconnaître
va-t-on expliquer qu'un pompier qui
assure des astreintes
le week end n'a pas droit ça fait partie
des conflits sociaux depuis maintenant
de très nombreuses années notre pays a
des dispositions supplémentaires au
moment de partir en retraite
exemple également qu'on peut donner pour
un certain nombre de fonctionnaires des
policiers etc
le problème c'est que jean-philippe le
premier ministre donne plutôt l'exemple
des conducteurs par exemple de bus qui
ne gains qui ne parte pas à la retraite
au même âge qu'il travaille à paris ou
au havre par exemple oui mais on peut
pas non plus faire des équivalences en
permanence les conducteurs de la ratp
des métros comment un 5 heures le matin
et sont dans les tunnels toute la
journée
enfin des exemples concrets c'est ce qui
a fait partie des négociations des
conventions collectives depuis des
années dans ce pays donc on peut pas
simplifié comme ça le sujet vous savez
quand on parle de simplification
je pense à la réforme de la fusion des
régions on a vu que d'une façon générale
le résultat n'était pas du tout au
niveau des objectifs qui avaient été
fixés
donc il faut se méfier des grands mots
dans ce genre de circonstances
le sujet central et je reviens au
rapport de loi parce que c'est le seul
élément tangible que nous ayons c'est
qu'il est prévu pour que tout le monde
comprenne bien l'élément du débat qu'il
est prévu la fameuse règle d'or c'est à
dire que le budget consacré aux
retraites représentera au maximum 14 %
du pib dans le pays
c'est une absurdité totale pourquoi
parce que le nombre de retraités va
augmenter considérablement
apart en 2040 voyez vous il y aura 8
millions de français qui de plus
qu'aujourd'hui qui auront plus de 60 ans
donc la question est essentielle puisque
on va garder une même sa mort on est
aujourd'hui dans un état où la
croissance est totalement à
tonnes et en même temps le diviseur
c'est à dire le nom de personne pour
qu'il va falloir partager cette somme
qui restera la même
va augmenter c'est une opération de
division du début de collège et public
en marche ne le comprends pas je pense
que monsieur bul gilani peu l'ont
expliqué très simplement vous avez
évoqué le cas des pompiers en posant une
question on va faire répondre
eric alauzet le membre de la majorité
sur ce sur ce plateau
il ya des pompiers c'est une somme de
cas particuliers cette réforme des
retraites il ya aussi les policiers ou
les enseignants deux corporations dont
on sait que si le système est appliqué
elles vont perdre des avantages comment
expliquer aujourd'hui aux pompiers mais
aussi aux policiers aux enseignants des
professions qui demande plus de
reconnaissance déjà qu'elles vont perdre
leur avantage aujourd'hui elles vont pas
forcément perles parce que on sait par
exemple pour les fonctionnaires les
primes qui n'étaient pas intégrées dans
les enseignants non plaintes n'ont pas
de prime c'est tout problème il faudra
adapter pour chacun pour les professions
libérales il ya des spécificités aussi
je ne connais bien
donc il faudra adapter pour chaque
profession et d'ailleurs pour chaque
branche professionnelle aucune décision
ne sera prise
qu'ils ne soient partagées avec la
branche en question moi je repère très
simple sur la justice c'est l'espérance
de vie
il ya des métiers alors change parfois
de métier dans sa ville mais si on fait
un métier pendant trente ans on sait que
selon le métier que l'on peut que l'on
pratique on a une espérance de vie
significativement différente pour moi
c'est un critère très important de
réglage de du de l'année de départ en
retraite par rapport au temps on peut
espérer toucher sa sa retraite il faut
aller sur des choses relativement simple
voilà donc il faut faire il faut plus de
justice mais ça il n'y a pas cinquante
levier soit cotisent plus longtemps soit
on augmente les cotisations on l'a fait
j'ai dit à quel niveau on était arrivés
28% pourra pas demander beaucoup plus
tard bien sûr encore d'accord avec
bastien photo si on a plus de monde au
travail
si ça c'est là c'est l'économie plus de
monde au travail plus de cotisations
enfin on sait que dans la mondialisation
cyberoam son pub de la comptabilité
simplifiée pas trop mais je sais c'est
qu'il fait pas preuve la règle d'or
c'est même logique jeudi à expliquer
quand je les routes et augmenter les
années de l'année le nombre d'années de
cotisations augmenter les cotisations ou
éventuellement contenir le niveau des
retraites et je vous avais envoyé une
courbe qui montre bien le conseil
d'orientation des retraites montre bien
comment
nos aînés il ya 30 ans avait à peu près
30% de moins de retraite que les actuels
et comment nos enfants alors la cedh et
prédictifs donc il ya une marge d'erreur
ont entre 15 et 30% à leur tour deux
mois que les retraités actuels
voilà ces deux salons c'est notre jeu
c'est garantir pour nos enfants tout en
maintenant le maximum de protection
vis-à-vis des retraites actuel est de
ceux qui vont arriver très
progressivement fera taire sur 15 ans
sur un tank bas quand on a 45 ans qu'on
a cotisé dans un certain esprit de
certaines règles il faut pas de gommer
ce qu'on a lu mais il faut être très
progressive pour ramener progressivement
le changement j'ai jasé reviennent aux
enfants j'aimerais qu'on revienne à la
problématique de profession particulière
sur les parce que c'est ça qui est
explosif finalement politiquement et
socialement sur les policiers les
enseignants comment comment on fait
accepter une telle réforme jean marie
sermier
écoutez moi je crois qu'on fait accepter
une réforme quand elle est juste
or aujourd'hui nous n'avons que de la
concertation de façade faut bien appeler
un chat un chat qui a été concerté
concrètement est ce que aujourd'hui les
organisations professionnelles après
avoir été reçu par monsieur delevoye a
eu une voix au chapitre
non moi je crois qu'il n'y a pas de ne
pas opposer les français les uns contre
les autres
il n'ya pas de génération dorée il n'ya
pas de génération qui ont eu un avantage
sur les autres et il faut simplement
qu'on ait le souci pour les générations
qui arrivent d'avoir la capacité de
leurs finances et la retraite
et puis il n'ya pas non plus de métier
doré et il n'y a pas des métiers qui
nécessite effectivement qu'on ne les a
bon qu'on les abandonne
je crois qu'il ya un vrai travail de
fond à faire nous attendons depuis deux
ans et demi
d'avoir des propositions qui soient mis
sur la table et à ce jour malgré la
visite du premier ministre à lons le
saunier nous sommes bien obligés de
constater qu'il n'y a toujours rien
alors vous parlez de génération dorée je
relève quand même c'est un une pierre
dans le jardin d'erika l'oseo et vous
soyez les deux parce que eric alauzet à
parler de génération dorée il ya 18 mois
oui quelque chose comme ça c'est un
sparadrap qui vous colle comme au
capitaine haddock est ce que vous
regrettez ces mots alors vous l'avez
expliqué c'est parce que les retraités
actuels gagne plus que leurs parents est
sûrement plus aussi que les générations
futures comme l'expression était pas
juste et surtout l'été car est capturée
par une revue qui s'appelle les
contribuables associés qui en
fait une montagne j'aurais peut-être dû
x utilisé l'expression d'âge d'or et
cette courbe en cloche qui est méconnu
où nous sommes en haut de la cloche
aujourd'hui où le niveau de revenu des
retraités est au dessus des actifs alors
qu'ils étaient 20 à 30% en dessous dans
les années 70 et qu'il sera pour nos
enfants jeanne et j'assiste voilà c'est
simple
simplement ça il ya eu un détournement
de sens peut-être parce que j'ai été
aussi maladroits dans la formule pense
que la formule d'âge d'or est beaucoup
plus adapté que celui que j'avais
utilisé je crois que mon collègue qui a
lancé volontairement et je lui en veux
pas le propos acquiesce je crois que le
terme d'âge d'or est beaucoup plus
adapté
les échos évoquent jeudi matin un plan b
c'est à dire que le gouvernement au lieu
de lancer la réforme en 2025 comme le
prévoit le fameux rapport delevoye
pourrait le reporter aux calendes
grecques
et finalement cette réforme ne pourrait
concerner que les futurs actifs
finalement on reporterait donc la
réforme d'une quarantaine d'années et
surtout si on l'appliqué aux futurs
actifs on est certain qu'il ne
manifesteront pas dans la rue bastien
photo que pensez vous de cette option
gouvernementale vous voyez bien que là
on est dans des contradictions total on
explique qu'il faut réformer vite et
puis finalement on apprend maintenant
que c'est comme vous le dites pour les
calendes grecques on explique qu'il faut
un régime universel j'entends dessus à
l'oser dire qu'il faut tenir compte de
chacune des spécificités
professionnelles pour les anciennes etc
donc on est dans la contradiction
majuscules dans cette affaire en réalité
on a un problème économique majeur
j'en parle demain ya une manifestation à
belfort vous savez un plan de
licenciement qui sagnières ce samedi
pardon hier chanel l'émission est
enregistrée au voilà en réalité les
salariés dans cette affaire demain vont
être sur le carreau une partie d'entre
eux on sait pas combien encore
aujourd'hui 500 600 700 800 il n'y a
plus de politique industrielle dans le
pays
le problème est là parce que ce qui est
posé d'abord dans le régime des
retraites
quand je parlais de l'égalité salariale
entre les femmes et les hommes c'est de
cela dont je veux parler d'une certaine
façon c'est les lignes de recettes
comment relancer les codes l'activité
économique dans les vieux pays
industrialisés
à l'heure de la mondialisation ou non
fait entrer en concurrence des systèmes
économiques sociaux je dirais même aussi
iter sur le plan de la santé publique
sur le plan de l'environnement qui sont
totalement différents et à ces questions
là d'une façon générale les libéraux
répondre le libre marché
monsieur macro et monsieur philippe sont
pris dans leurs contradictions
il n'y a pas de lignes de recettes
organisé parce que sur le dossier de
general electric
typiquement il n'y a pas assez loin du
cir mais non on s'en éloigne pas parce
que demain les 500 600 700 ou 800
salariés de general electric qui vont
être sur le carreau il ne cotiseront
plus au système de retraite
et là on a un problème dans l'entrée des
recettes du système général de retraite
c'est ça la question centrale
aujourd'hui
alors il ya des dispositifs je parlais
tout à l'heure de l'égalité salariale
entre les femmes et les hommes
mais on pourrait parler aussi quelle est
la part de contribution des revenus du
capital au système des retraites eric
alauzet je vous laisse répondre
l'égalité hommes-femmes et les salaires
oui mais c'est bien que c'est pas une
baguette magique qui va faire qu'on va
du jour au lendemain
demander aux employeurs qu'ils soient
publics ou privés d'augmenter de
plusieurs dizaines de milliards comme ça
spontanément les rémunérations des
salariés
donc c'est une image que vous présentez
qui est séduisante mais qui est
totalement gratuit jeu j'aimerais bien
qu'elle soit qu'elle soit possible enfin
franchement personne personne va vous
croire quand quand vous dites ça voilà
donc soit soyons allons vers l'égalité
non c'est la façon dont vous vendez les
choses de façon comme ça je vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir quand mois
d'après 20 ans le rejet qualité
hommes-femmes
elle progresse l'industrie dation dont
vous parlez pour la première fois on a
une augmentation des exportations depuis
15 ans donc ce qui se passe dans leur
franche comté à belfort hadji est
catastrophique je vous en veux pas leur
venue à l'expliquer aux chaleurs les
effectifs c'est catastrophique je pense
qu'ils le savent ils venus de vivre dans
le temps l'heure dans leur chair et dans
leur famille
l'emploi s'améliore un petit peu c'est
pas fantastique on a on est dans la
mondialisation ou la vidéo tout est fait
pour qu'il de l'emploi non seulement
pour que les gens puissent vivre
dignement leur métier mais aussi pour
qu'ils puissent cotiser à la sécu
sociale pour leur retraite c'est tout ça
est lié sommes d'accord eric alauzet
mais ne soyons pas croire qu'on va comme
ça d'un coup de baguette magique tout
réglé c'est pas vrai vous le savez au
fond puisse vous puisque l'on parle
d'industrie pouvez vous garantir que la
pénibilité sera prise en compte dans le
calcul des retraites
en tout cas aujourd'hui en tout cas pour
la part qui est de ma responsabilité je
mettrai toute mon énergie à le faire ça
veut dire que ce n'est au niveau de la
majorité si la grande majorité des
députés sont attachés à cette notion est
le premier ministre vous on a entendu il
ya un instant l'a annoncé et annoncé
jean marie sermier vous disiez tout à
l'heure pour l'instant de fait que
concertée allons dans le fond des choses
pour les professions qui vont perdre des
acquis sociaux aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il
faut des compensations notamment de type
salariale mais évidemment il ya des
négociations avoir par broche sens
opposé comme je le disais les français
les uns contre les autres et puis cette
pensée à quelle branche si on va dans le
détail y compris des branches qui
aujourd'hui bénéficient de départ en
retraite plus pu plus avancé donc je
crois qu'il faut être très clair là
dessus et puis vous avez aussi des
caisses qui sont très excédentaire et
les professions qui ont des caisses très
excédentaire donc il ne suffira pas
d'aller chercher l'argent là où il est
question est excédentaire pour pouvoir
faire en sorte que l'ensemble des
français puissent trouver une solution
mais je dis qu'il toucherait pas au
trésor de guerre en quelque sorte de ces
professions libérales ya notamment les
avocats qui ont des caciques c'est
d'ailleurs voilà je crois que c'est pas
la première fois que le président de la
république dit quelque chose et revient
c'est négociable
c'est bien après déjà ce qu'il a dit moi
ce qui m'inquiète aussi c'est par
exemple cette notion de retraite par
points la retraite parfois ça veut dire
quoi au fond c'est à dire que vous avez
effectivement acquis un certain nombre
de points au cours de votre vie certes
il s'agit toujours d'une rue d'une
recette par répartition d'une retraite
par répartition mais ça veut dire que le
prix du point la valeur du point
elle est déterminée chaque année
notamment par la loi de finances et que
ça peut être extrêmement dangereux parce
qu'on peut réduire comme ça
la retraite le plafond mais on peut
réduire en une année en un budget en un
vote de façon significative la retraite
des français
donc ça me rassure pas les jeunes
générations pas plus que le système
actuel voilà ici parce que le système
actuel on sait à peu près où j'ai
commencé cette émission en disant que
les jeunes générations n'a lui a
confiance dans le système actualise son
sac jouit mais ce que non vous êtes en
train de me dire
que le système en points ne rassure pas
plus que le système actuel joue ici le
système actuel et permet d'avoir une
notion de ce qu'on va toucher assez
précisément simplement le problème c'est
qu'il sera extrêmement déficitaire et là
je rejoins complètement ce que disait
eric alauzet il est excédentaire en 2019
parce qu'il ya eu des réformes
précédentes mais si nous ne réformons
pas en 2021
on sera je crois à 10 milliards de
déficit juste deux points
le système en points ça veut juste dire
que le point aura la même valeur pour
tous hélas rien à voir oui mais ça veut
dire qu'on peut la changer
on peut la terminer à tout moment c'est
déjà une petite précision c'est ça
l'objectif
l'universalité c'est ça le point vaut la
même chose pour tout le monde ensuite
sur l'évolution des retraites ce que je
viens d'expliquer sur cetet 30% de moins
il ya 40 ans et ça va être entre 15 et
30 pour 30% demain dans trente ou
quarante ans c'est points ou pas points
c'est pareil c'est une enveloppe fermée
les retraites avec les cotisations c'est
vrai il n'ya pas de l'argent miraculeux
et les dépenses ne servent qu'aux
retraite mais ça dépend non je déjà
aujourd'hui les retraités et pas aussi
les retraités les nouveaux retraités
bakhti marais dépendez le temps
d'accuser gens mais une fois toutes
choses égales par ailleurs des retraités
qui partent aujourd'hui part déjà avec
un peu moins que l'année précédente
complètement du ratio que les à pois et
les retraités ça c'est une façon de
corriger mais ça ne change rien aux
principes se salit de juin mais non
c'est pas le point qui rend l'avenir
incertain
c'est simplement le fait de la
disponibilité financière le
vieillissement le et c'est une bonne
nouvelle plus en plus de personnes à la
retraite et qui vieillissent longtemps
tant mieux mais ça pèse sur l'équilibré
et fait beau le 5 décembre non c'est moi
qui pose les questions souplet le 5
décembre très fécond
interprofessionnelle grève
interprofessionnelle est ce que les
syndicats la gauche espère faire plier
le gouvernement sur cette question
un scénario à la 95 on va dire d'abord
je me sens pas autorisé à parler à lons
non mais oh des syndicats ces pour cela
vous devez invités bien sûr je vais vous
donner le mien
la question de la mobilisation populaire
dollars et elle est évidemment centrale
dans le rapport de force qui s'annonce
avec le gouvernement mais vous savez je
n'ai jamais cru à l'histoire des grands
soirs je crois beaucoup plus à la
sédimentation des petits matins en
réalité si on voulait donner un exemple
pour que tout le monde comprenne
l'absurdité de ce qui est proposé dans
le rapport de le voir ça tient en une
chose le système par points va bonifier
de façon excessive selon moi les
personnes qui décideront de partir en
retraite plus tardivement à 65 66 67 ans
la réalité c'est que dans un pays où il
ya 700 mille huit cent mille jeunes qui
sont en attente de situation stable
d'emploi d'abord sans parler tous ceux
qui sont en stage qui sont en cdd qui ne
peuvent pas miser sur l'avenir qu'ils ne
peuvent pas fondées de foyers qui ne qui
se posent la question peuvent obtenir de
prêt pour pouvoir se loger
on est dans une société qui est en train
d'organiser un système qui va
privilégier des gens qui ne rêve que
d'une chose c'est de partir en retraite
en tout cas en les encourageant ou les
forçant à partir en retraite plus
tardivement et en laissant sur le bord
de la route toutes ses forces vives
je pense que l'art et le système par
points favorisera cela c'est dans toutes
les simulations qui sont à la fin du
document du rapport delevoye et riscle
eauze et eric alauzet sur la
mobilisation de la rue très rapidement
parce que archos est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui
est ce que la majorité peut reculer et
notamment reculé sur l'application de la
réforme
face à la mobilisation de la rue oui un
peu pour l'instant on en a des grands
principes que j'ai énoncé précédemment
et sur les choses très concrètes on est
très loin du compte ya pas encore de
propositions donc je vois pas bien
quelles seront les sujets de
protestation à un peu le critique en
disant ya rien pour l'instant cantonnés
les carnets et ont remis une offre un
panel papillon va pas remettre c'est une
question de mois c'est pas une question
d'années la des décisions seront prises
aujourd'hui en il est urgent de prendre
des décisions il faudra les mettre en
place très lentement et dans l'article 1
de la loi il y aura le fait que pour
chaque métier qu'on a évoqué pompiers
etc
il faudra que ce soit validé par la
branche pour chaque match de grand
je suis à lausanne en or rose lors à la
mention de ces commentaires je suis
désolé messieurs il va être midi la
réforme des retraites on va en parler
dans la suite de dimanche en politique
avec francis letellier qui reçoit et
yannick jadot bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]